la estación tiene un segmento ruso que
se encarga de los sistemas de propulsión
y un segmento estadounidense que se
encarga de la electricidad de los
sistemas de soporte vital en términos
prácticos que significa el fin de esta
cooperación hay posibilidad de
reemplazar el módulo de propulsión a
tiempo para mantenerla en órbita
depende de lo que respiramos a tiempo es
muy difícil que sea algo inmediato
cualquier cosa del espacio toma tiempo y
no es sencillo
si es que no se reemplazará y dejarán de
actuar hay un plazo de varios años antes
de que la estación caiga de forma
descontrolada entonces en varios años si
es posible reemplazarla pero depende
fundamentalmente de la voluntad política
y en este minuto es muy difícil predecir
cualquier cosa bueno en los últimos años
eeuu tanto con la nasa como con empresas
privadas ha propiciado importantes
desarrollos en materia de envíos al
espacio por ejemplo space sex tiene su
cohete falcon line y su cápsula propia
que es la dragón en qué áreas se puede
hablar de interdependencia con rusia en
estos momentos
bueno tal como tú decías al comienzo la
estación necesita periódicamente una o
dos veces al mes
encender cohetes para levantarla un poco
porque vaya poquito bajando hacia la
tierra y eso tiene exclusividad por la
potencia de los motores en el módulo
ruso en este minuto si es que no
hubiesen iniciativas como las de spacex
no me cabe duda que la colaboración con
la unión soviética con rusia perdón
seguirían en pie porque hasta hace unos
años atrás rusia era el único país que
tenían el
mecanismo de subir y bajar cosas y
personal a la estación espacial entonces
era absolutamente inviable romper
relaciones hoy gracias a todo el
adelanto de spacex y otras compañías
gringas se pueden dar el lujo de romper
relaciones y esperar arreglar el
problema dentro de pocos años
bueno y finalizar una cooperación de
este tipo claramente trae pérdidas en el
ámbito investigativo pero quién pierde
más eeuu y sus aliados o rusia
es muy difícil porque la pérdida es para
todos mira las colaboraciones
científicas son entre individuos entre
personas entre laboratorios o
instituciones y cuando se dañan es muy
difícil recuperarlo imagínate que hay
una prohibición desde rusia o desde eeuu
a por ejemplo no sé yo trabajar contigo
si es que después de esto termina y se
rearmen las relaciones yo puedo seguir
conversando contigo pero la legalidad ya
sea desde rusia o desde eeuu es muy
lenta de cambiar y es muy probable que
nos prohíban conversar durante varios
años o quizás una década entonces los
temas de colaboración son muy sensibles
y es realmente una pena que se estén
rompiendo quién sufre más sufre más
probablemente que queda más aislado que
me imagino en este caso es en la gran
mayoría de los casos serán los rusos
pero esa no debiera ser la pregunta la
pregunta de ir a hacer cómo hacerlo para
que suframos todos menos